look gorgeous as always
q so you guys don't really look gorgeous
do they not do we I don't know I mean I
go I think I do thank or eaten handsome
were handsome right
we're not gorgeous she'll put down if I
say gorgeous I feel very feminine yeah
it's something like a grandmother says
like he's got my son is gorgeous my
grandson is gorgeous when I was little I
went to my grandmother lived with us and
I went into her room and she we used to
embarrass me because she would pet my
hair and should say you have beautiful
hair it should be a girl's hair it
should be a girl's hair and now you live
for your hair yeah exactly did you say
your hips they should be a girl's it I
didn't say that
Joerg yeah it took care of her it's a
whole story listen you've got things to
talk about you've been in Europe promote
on this film I have yeah I was in Zurich
for the Zurich Film Festival which is my
first time in Zurich I've never been to
Zurich it's beautiful um
Zurich is very German mmm cuz zoic you
know it's I mean I don't whatever but
you know what I mean
um I was driving with my writing partner
well and the exit in German is I'm so
mature sorry it's Al spot that's the
word for exit yeah yeah so we were just
having we had a lot of really immature
giggles about as far so you're driving
down the highway and instead of exit
every where it says house for just would
you laugh every single every single time
we left just as hard just as hard if not
harder
I make jokes like oh my god y'all get is
such an alpha what is y'all spot my
house wat doesn't smell yeah it's like
Americans abroad its aren't we aren't we
a treat